fue uno de los anuncios más aplaudidos
del discurso sobre el estado de la
nación de Vladimir Putin la suspensión
por parte de Moscú del tratado New Start
el último pacto de control de armas
nucleares que queda con Estados Unidos
quieren una derrota estratégica sobre
nosotros e intentar llegar a nuestras
instalaciones nucleares por eso me veo
obligado a anunciar hoy que Rusia
suspende su participación en el tratado
de armas estratégicas ofensivas
el pacto firmado por Estados Unidos y
Rusia en 2010 limita a cada país a 1550
cabezas nucleares desplegadas Y
restringea ambos países a 700 misiles
nucleares desplegados el tratado también
permite la supervisión conjunta de los
arsenales nucleares de cada parte a lo
que Washington dice que Moscú se ha
negado en numerosas ocasiones Putin
afirma que la decisión es una respuesta
a lo que denomina acciones hostiles de
occidente contra Rusia
Reino Unido y Francia También tienen
arsenales nucleares están mejorando y
desarrollando y están dirigidos contra
nosotros contra Rusia Simplemente no
podemos ignorar esto no podemos
permitirnoslo especialmente hoy
Estados Unidos no tardó en tachar de
irresponsable la decisión de Moscú
mientras que la Unión Europea y la otan
advirtieron de que la medida podría
marcar El Fin Del control de armamento
posterior a la Guerra Fría
más armas nucleares y menos control de
armamento hacen que el mundo sea más
peligroso hoy pido a Rusia que
reconsidere su decisión de suspender su
participación en el nuevo acuerdo
Putin también insinuó que Rusia no
descartará la reanudación de las pruebas
de armas nucleares sugiriendo que no
dará marcha atrás a corto plazo en la
Guerra de Ucrania